Christian is now going to introduce the final
project for this class. But a note before he
does. The final project is a digital device,
something you keep in your pocket, something you work
by gesture and touch, maybe voice. You might
wonder, gee, everything in this class has been physical,
physical products. So, how do the principles we've
learned in the class apply to this new domain?
Well that's why we're doing it. We want you to know that all the things you've
learned apply to all products. It doesn't matter whether it's [SOUND] a physical
product like this, where the physical affordances are very important. Or
to a digital product like this, where gestures and maybe voice and touching
is very important. All the principles apply
with maybe different emphasis. So for example,
with a physical product affordances are important.
With this, it is the signifiers that
are critical. Doesn't matter, all the principles
of this course apply to all products,
perishible, digital, physical.